Bonjour, je m'appelle Sabrina Wallace, et mes parents faisaient tous deux partie de Space Force en 1969.
Il se trouve que j'ai un joli cristal de forme similaire.
Maintenant, beaucoup de gens aiment dire des choses que nous n'aimons pas nécessairement aborder et aider les gens à comprendre des choses difficiles à comprendre parce que, vous savez, tout le monde est occupé en ce moment à se préparer à la guerre des drones, à la guerre des drones électromagnétiques.
Nous l'avons fait en Irak, puis juste avant, et vous savez, le pays va entrer en guerre d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Que ce soit ou non, vous savez, notre propre peuple ou autre chose, nous avons un sérieux déficit d'apprentissage aux États-Unis.
Qu'il ait été conçu et conçu ou non.
Je vais laisser d'autres personnes en parler.
Ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui, c'est vous montrer exactement ce que vous devez expliquer à vos propres enfants afin que nous puissions éviter la révolution de la bouche.
Je suis presque sûre que c'est ce qui les met réellement en colère.
Et c'est ce que nous allons faire avec l'éducation.
Je vais donc commencer.
Nous ne le sommes pas.
Je m'appelle Sabrina Wallace.
Je suis l'enfant d'Austin.
Et les membres de ma famille sont impliqués dans des projets noirs, SEPS, des projets d'accès spécial.
Je suis donc membre du BAIER et mon grand-père est Bernard Heinrichs ici, et ce nom est M..
Il a épousé Helen Harding, et Helen Harding est directement liée à Pius Levi.
Mon père était Steven Garland Davis.
Ma mère est Lynne Gene Scheer.
Ils sont tous les deux des Central Super secrets.
En 1969, alors que je travaillais sur le projet Silence, I Am a Modified Child grâce à l'expérimentation pour l'augmentation humaine menée par la Fondation Menninger.
Tout ce que cela signifie, c'est que j'ai des cicatrices que la plupart des gens n'ont pas pour l'architecture de John von Neumann.
Ce n'est pas une interface cerveau-machine.
C'est la masse corporelle.
C'est impossible.
Et ça sonne.
Encore une fois ?
Je m'accroche à cela.
Voici donc la liste des mariages de mes parents.
OK.
Voici les manifestes de vol au départ d'Edgewood Arsenal pour mon grand-oncle.
65/70 Army Chemical, Fort Dietrich.
Vers où ?
Texas.
New York, Corée du Nord.
Juste une qui ne suffit pas.
Eleanor Hall C'est toujours pour les trois.
Je suis probablement ici, j'ai participé aux projets Mothman et à la construction de véhicules pour les hommes en noir.
Maintenant, l'interface pour les cicatrices de John von Neumann se trouve juste en dessous.
J'en vois un là-bas.
Bien sûr, je suis plus âgé maintenant, mais c'est ton cœur.
OK, il s'agit donc d'une interface corps-machine avec une base de données souterraine appelée Next the Longer, qui est IBM.
Donc, dans mon cours d'allemand au lycée, je l'ai mal orthographié.
Nick est tombé sur la droite.
OK.
Pourquoi est-ce important ?
Parce que si les gens disent des choses comme ça, ils feraient mieux de vous montrer des preuves, des preuves viables, sinon je ne les écouterais pas.
OK, voici donc un peu plus de documentation, puis nous allons commencer la discussion intellectuelle.
OK.
Voici donc ma famille et Garland.
Mon grand-père, Garland Davis, était un Marine de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mmm, hum.
Et d'abord, il a épousé Elizabeth Kraft.
Mais je pense que quelque chose avec l'ADN n'a pas marché.
Alors il a épousé ma mère.
Tante.
OK.
Vous avez donc travaillé pour une entreprise composée de mes parents et de mon grand-oncle.
Oh, désolée.
J'ai oublié une chose.
J'habite chez mon oncle, mon grand-oncle.
Il l'est donc.
Il a toujours été l'une de mes personnes préférées.
C'est un homme très gentil.
Oh, allez.
Cette fois, j'avais tout ce qu'il fallait pour raconter l'histoire.
OK.
Oh.
Tellement sudiste.
J'ai donc une histoire totalement différente de celle de mes parents.
On ne m'a jamais rien dit.
Rien J'ai donc grandi et je le voulais.
Et ils m'ont dit que rien n'existait sauf ce que vous pouviez voir.
Et je voulais savoir ce que sont tous ces trucs électromagnétiques ?
J'ai grandi dans les années 80, dans les années 90.
Je suis née en 1979, et si vous parliez de l'aura, tout le monde vous a mise dans un coin et vous a demandé de rejoindre leur groupe de lecteurs.
Et j'étais toujours assise là à me dire : « Tu te rends compte que c'est une partie du corps.
Et j'aime bien : « Non, tu es stupide ».
Il faut avoir une religion.
Je n'ai jamais réalisé ce que j'étais.
Je ne savais pas pourquoi les gens agissaient de manière aussi stupide, par exemple pourquoi mentiriez-vous à propos d'une partie du corps ?
Et pourtant, mes parents étaient des écureuils secrets.
Cela représente quatre niveaux d'application de la loi supérieurs à tout ce que voient les civils.
Et ce sont les ex.
L'élite secrète.
Quoi ?
C'est un service secret d'élite.
Et c'est à peu près tout.
Une fois que vous y êtes, ce sont les forces de l'ordre secrètes.
Pour l'instant, tu dois passer au niveau supérieur.
OK, maintenant je dois passer au niveau supérieur.
Ils sont sérieux.
Oui, je peux passer au niveau supérieur.
C'est vrai.
Je suis donc allée travailler pour une entreprise de Louisville, dans le Kentucky, appelée High Speed Access.
Et c'est à ce moment-là qu'ils m'ont envoyé mes papiers à travailler pour qu'ils puissent les voir sur place.
Ils ont juste pris la sueur de leur vieil adulte.
C'est le retour dans l'espace pour nous.
Le véritable backend de ce pays.
J'ai été l'un des deux techniciens à relier l'État du Wisconsin du réseau commuté au haut débit.
Je suis donc très clair.
L-3 Harris ou C 24, toutes les différentes manières dont nous gérons toutes sortes de renseignements, le programme PRISM de la NSA, y compris les paquets de données.
L'ingénierie réseau n'est pas la même chose que l'installation d'un modem câble.
Je dois travailler avec le technicien et l'ingénieur de l'usine.
Personne ne loue une usine dans ce domaine.
Et personne n'a été embauché pour occuper ce poste à part celui qui l'a fait.
Oui, j'avais 19 ans.
Donc, pour le tourisme international, alors que je continue ici, les gens n'ont vraiment rien à me dire parce que je suis exactement là où je vous dis que je suis.
Corps entier.
Excusez mon pied sale.
Très bien, ma sœur.
Voyons voir.
J'ai demandé des services techniques, un réseau de campus professionnel surveillé par UW Whitewater, divers progiciels, dont beaucoup d'or dans le réseau Maps, du HP vintage, une vue ouverte lors de brèves interactions avec Snort.
Les opérations du deuxième quart de travail incluent le traitement des bases de données à l'aide de PeopleSoft, de huit routeurs et commutateurs de codage mis à jour, la collaboration avec Visio pour créer une carte optique des formations initiées sur le campus.
Pour ce qui est simple, bien sûr, il s'agit d'un état complet, comme une petite partie.
Lorsque je suis allée au centre des opérations du réseau, à Louisville, ou est-ce que je voulais créer l'un de ces consultants en réseau chez Omni Resources à Green Bay ?
Problèmes, conflits avec le système d'exploitation, problèmes avec les étudiants, conflits avec Shock West.
La société propriétaire a développé un logiciel, assisté avec Cisco Fixed Firewall, assistant du programme Department of Corrections Wales, Wisconsin, installé et mis en œuvre un programme de suivi interne.
Département de maintenance des installations de l'école pour garçons Ethan Allen.
Développer des bases de données, y accéder et fournir une orientation pour Oracle Implementation Résoudre les problèmes de réseau et de bureau au sein des départements et une tâche importante.
D'octobre 1999 au 22 mai, Charter Communications a maintenu une mise à niveau, enseigné et dépanné un réseau ISP composé de trois réseaux Cisco, Kong Comm 21 et Bay Networks, avait cinq racks installés et en avait en saison.
Colin Cable, responsable des rapports hebdomadaires et mensuels, de certains tests d'utilisation de la bande passante et des circuits, des modems câbles retournés, des problèmes de garantie ou de redéploiement, de la couverture de la lumière, de la zone de responsabilité de plus de 12 000 clients, de l'installation et de la maintenance de serveurs Cisco AC 5300 pour sept pools distincts, a surveillé la bande passante dans des routeurs Cisco 7200 configurés avec des mises à niveau pour 9 000 clients et gère les relations entre le câblo-opérateur et les techniciens à Plainfield, dans l'Illinois, tout en formant le nouveau personnel aux postes techniques et administratifs en janvier 2001.
Consultez la liste des logiciels et c'est quelque chose qui a été définitivement désactivé en 2004 parce qu'elle a été déprimée par son propre gouvernement.
Pour fermer la porte à cette question, êtes-vous toujours télépathe selon les projets ?
Tu sais, peut-être pas, mais maintenant ça va être amusant.
Alors, où allons-nous aller à partir de là ?
Nous allons entrer dans la réalité d'aujourd'hui en 2022.
Et d'abord, nous allons tirer une petite leçon du passé.
Dans mon travail, lorsque je travaillais à UW Whitewater.
Elle a un énorme aimant en dessous d'elle dans un satellite fixe en orbite terrestre basse au-dessus d'elle.
Et dans les années 1970, UW Whitewater possédait un tas de logiciels qui traînaient pour toutes ces bases de données souterraines de Nick Furlong, d'IBM, etc.
Ils sont sous terre.
Ce n'est donc pas une certitude, c'est peut-être une certitude.
Il s'agit avant tout du refroidissement.
Encore une fois, quand j'étais enfant, je grandissais en dessinant des choses comme celles-ci : ils testaient l'interface cerveau-cerveau pour détecter la télépathie synthétique.
Et on ment aux gens depuis longtemps à propos de cette partie électromagnétique du corps.
Et maintenant, nous traversons une crise dans notre pays.
Cela date de 1993, et c'est ainsi que fonctionnent les configurations Bluetooth Zigbee.
Voilà à quoi ils ressemblent.
Et c'est exactement ainsi qu'ils procèdent dans le domaine des télécommunications.
Et je vais me montrer tout ça.
Mais je tiens à souligner qu'ils faisaient des tests sur des enfants.
Oui, c'est ce que fait notre gouvernement.
Les parents, mes parents, ils viennent juste de te livrer.
C'est leur travail.
C'est un déploiement secret pour Synchrone.
Nan.
Désolée, les gars.
Non, j'y reviens tout de même.
Ce voyage a donc vraiment commencé pour moi en tant qu'enfant, avec les problèmes d'action du scanner, c'est-à-dire simplement le contrôle de toute ma physiologie au lieu d'écouter les gens autour de moi me raconter une histoire me racontant comment m'empêcher de simplement sentir mon propre corps.
Et en grandissant depuis 1979, j'ai toujours trouvé cela bizarre, inhabituel, mais je ne le savais pas.
Je ne savais pas que les biofilms humains étaient au cœur de la surveillance.
Et une fois que je l'ai fait, ça n'allait pas.
Et ma famille m'a obligée à partir pendant près de dix ans parce que je n'avais jamais le droit de dire quoi que ce soit de Perch.
Chris C'est l'automne.
En 2019, je me suis heurtée à une ambulance anglaise, et au téléphone, le gars dans l'ambulance m'a dit : Emmenez-la à l'héliport, emmenez-la au lodge, emmenez-la à la ferme.
Maintenant, je suis parfaitement sauvé par le gouvernement.
C'était la première fois que j'appelais une ambulance.
Je n'étais pas préparé à ça.
Puis j'ai su que les militaires me surveillaient.
Puis j'ai découvert une erreur commise par notre agence de renseignement de défense par l'intermédiaire de mes parents.
Pas vraiment Je travaille ici pour Charter, mais je suis capable de capter le radar et tous ces autres signaux électromagnétiques.
C'est naturel.
Le chien réagit de la même façon que moi.
Nous ne le disons pas aux gens à moins que vous ne soyez dans le Marine Corps pour avoir une idée de la situation.
Aujourd'hui, Stingray et Dirt Bikes utilisent la même partie du corps parce qu'elle est électromagnétique.
Et en 1953, le grand-oncle a ensuite ramené à la maison un tas de photos et de drones électromagnétiques et en 1953 et encore une fois, maman et papa ont travaillé en 1969 sur le projet Salus, qui contrôle à peu près tous les états moléculaires que nous avons à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur du corps humain.
Maintenant, si vous regardez les cellules, elles vous indiqueront la logistique et le mouvement et, en gros, tout ce qui se passe au niveau international par molécule.
Et tu y vas, c'est impossible.
C'est parce que vous ne connaissez pas le nano-Internet des objets, l'Internet industriel des objets, et le fait que bon nombre de ces systèmes d'interface machine existaient en 1958.
Alors pourquoi ne le dirais-tu pas aux gens ?
Je veux dire, Edgewood Arsenal.
Nous faisons des tests sur nos propres soldats.
Encore une fois au Vietnam avec mon grand-père.
Nous avons des drones électromagnétiques en 1953.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
C'est vrai.
Je suis donc venue ici en Virginie-Occidentale et les bizarreries avec l'ambulance, puis ça continue.
Encore plus de bizarrerie, des véhicules qui disparaissent.
Je vais donc aller dans les librairies et ils se posent cette question.
Oh, nous planifions pour le comté.
Je suis propriétaire, alors je suis allée de l'avant et j'ai construit 60 nouvelles installations ici, dans une ville de 200 habitants.
Ils ont été pris.
Ça a l'air bizarre.
Hein.
J'ai donc commencé à faire des recherches sur six g lo pin et, comme je viens de l'ingénierie des réseaux et de la cybersécurité, c'est l'un de mes domaines préférés, car je fais des environnements mathématiques et j'ai dû le faire parce que j'ai dû sous-réseau le back-end de Space Forces à des adresses à quatre points, qui ont été mises en vente en Floride l'année dernière à partir de là.
C'est vraiment intéressant.
Mais je l'ai découvert aussi.
Quoi qu'il en soit, lorsque vous êtes ingénieur réseau et que vous étudiez pour votre associé réseau certifié Cisco à l'époque, vous deviez créer un sous-réseau en binaire parce que nous n'avions pas assez d'adresses IP.
Donc oui, je lis les mathématiques binomiales.
Cela faisait partie de mon travail par le passé.
OK.
Donc, en ce qui concerne la cybersécurité, c'est le genre de choses de cette première partie qui sont totalement ennuyeuses, comme les couches secondaires, Internet et d'autres choses de ce genre.
Encore une fois, lorsque vous devez créer un sous-réseau, isoler vos clients et que vous êtes redevable à des milliers de personnes et qu'elles vous accusent de 300 000 dollars par minute de perte, il s'agit de communications charters à l'époque.
Ensuite, vous devez savoir ce que vous faites et vous ne pouvez pas vous tromper.
400 000 dollars en une minute.
Oui, c'est une sorte de pression que tu subis dans un tel travail.
N'oubliez pas qu'il n'y a que deux personnes dans tout l'État qui peuvent manipuler cet équipement.
Vous n'avez donc pas le droit de partir en vacances.
En gros, vous devez suivre un programme de baby-sitting.
Ouais.
Donc, sécurité du réseau, réseau personnel à 60 degrés.
Et elle va utiliser machine à machine, ce qui signifie qu'aucun humain ne sera impliqué dans un véhicule ad hoc.
Notez, par exemple, voici un attaquant, voici un drone.
Maintenant, j'ai quelques problèmes.
Tout d'abord, vous ne pouvez pas interrompre ce drone.
La déclaration 3000.09 du Pentagone l'affirme il y a plus de 11 ans et vous pouvez la trouver sur CSR.
Par exemple, en mai 2022, le Pentagone a déclaré : « Je pense que nos commandants sur le terrain doivent être capables de lire l'apprentissage automatique ».
Eh bien, il est clair que le commandant, le mari, en particulier le commandant, n'ont pas assisté au Symposium sur l'intelligence artificielle le 10 septembre 2020.
Si le commandant l'avait fait, il aurait su qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un système nerveux numérique de bout en bout et qu'aucun humain n'est impliqué, je cite, dans le projet Selous.
Qu'avons-nous appris au sujet de la livraison des produits ?
Donnez-leur le code.
La plateforme Salus est utilisée par NORTHCOM avec des mises à niveau destinées aux fournisseurs.
Ce qui change la donne, c'est que de nouveaux prototypes neuronaux sont en cours de développement et sont disponibles ici.
Alors quoi ?
Nouveau prototype neuronal Synchro pour commencer, le G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
What is Fuzing est une organisation spécialisée dans la vente de produits aux personnes qui les utilisent réellement.
Ils se sont ensuite disputés pour savoir s'il s'agissait de services réseau hybrides d'Amazon ou de services numérisés, et Microsoft et Amazon ont répondu ou m'ont accordé un contrat avec le gouvernement.
OK.
Puis c'est devenu encore plus étrange pour moi.
Et pendant que j'écoutais, ils ont parlé de services d'étiquetage des données.
Et je pense que c'est une énorme curation de données de base de données.
Et je pense à ce que les clients fournisseurs et moi avons écrit, c'est le ministère de la Défense.
Donc, pour cela, vous pouvez revenir au début et il est dit que c'est ainsi que l'équipe du Jake, je veux dire la Joint Artificial Intelligence Commission, dont le rôle est de créer l'IA.
réel et chacun peut et doit mettre en œuvre l'intelligence artificielle dans tout ce qu'il fait.
Des clients du ministère de la Défense.
Quels sont vos clients ?
Regarde ça.
Contrasting Tools est donc sous l'égide de Tradewinds et du projet Maven.
Je cite les conduits chauds utilisant des capteurs intelligents, le groupe de travail sur les biocapteurs sans fil 82.1 5.5, le groupe de travail spécialisé sur les réseaux de capteurs sans fil pour les normes internationales en électronique et en ingénierie, excusez-moi, électronique et génie électrique.
Project Maven utilise Pathfinder et moi-même pour vous regarder vous promener et penser à l'intérieur de votre maison en temps réel.
Et citons le projet MQ Nine Tethered to Ground.
C'est la directive 3000.09 du ministère de la Défense, qui affirme encore une fois que c'est pourquoi le commandant était grincheux parce qu'il disait que nous ne pouvions pas entendre ces machines, que nous ne pouvions pas les décoder par nature et que nous ne pouvions pas faire passer un signal.
Et je cite ici, à la porte, nous devons rendre le système de l'armée de l'air d'IBM plus cohérent avec tout le reste.
Nous allons créer un système nerveux numérique de bout en bout.
Au ministère de la Défense, nous devons redéfinir la manière de connecter toutes les plateformes d'IBM.
Que contrôlent-ils ?
Plateformes lesbiennes, véhicules autonomes.
Vous voulez dire des drones autonomes, des tanks, des Strykers ordinaires, toutes sortes de choses.
Avions, vérifiez.
Qu'en est-il d'autre ?
Absolument.
Internet industriel des objets dans ce milliard de personnes qui utilisent des véhicules autonomes et tout cela n'est que de l'air allié.
Mais vous pensiez que ce n'était qu'une question intelligente : vous devriez envisager la nouvelle méthode d'ingénierie RF pour sauver la situation, appelée « Route verte ».
Ce n'est pas une nouvelle fibre spécialisée le long de l'autoroute.
Quand on vous a demandé si vous pouviez simplement utiliser un peu de lumière pour déplacer le flanc montagneux où se trouvent les monarques et l'accès spécial au Curtis National Institute of Science and Technology pour le gouvernement, il paie les gens.
Ce n'est pas une blague.
Les projets noirs se souviennent que je ne paie pas vraiment 45 000 dollars pour un siège de toilette complet.
Non, ils ne le font pas.
Mais tu sais quoi ?
Ils font les vilains iris.
Pour que les gens aient une telle pile, ils doivent saisir cinq codes pour cacher où va tout l'argent, l'allocation des ressources, la logistique et l'expédition, puis la réaffectation des personnes chargées des projets d'accès spécial, puis la réaffectation de la personne chargée de les protéger, de les suivre, de les retrouver ou du ministère de la Défense sur une liste pour la modification des projets d'accès spécial.
Cela devient incontrôlable et tout est open source.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus à ce sujet et le rechercher sur Google.
C'est donc notre problème ici.
Vous voulez donc m'expliquer quels sont ces biocapteurs et de quoi parlez-vous ?
Un drone MQ Nine Reaper.
C'est lié à mon ADN.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Et au fait, qui sont tes clients ?
En fait.
Cybersécurité.
Ouais.
Premier symposium sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Ils leur ont dit que tous les humains étaient à l'écart, donc je devrais le dire au système nerveux numérique de bout en bout pour ces plateformes connectées aux humains hors du processus et dans le raisonnement, permettre au responsable actuel d'utiliser directement les cellules de crédit de la science des données et.
Depuis que je suis enfant.
Entretiens sur l'interface machine.
Bases de données quantiques.
Corrélation des gestionnaires.
Pourquoi feraient-ils ça maintenant ?
Le nouveau réseau personnel à 60 personnes utilisera donc votre corps pour acheminer les données.
Et avant que vous ne pensiez, oh non, ils nous diraient que cela a été fait en 2005.
C'est ce qu'est le réseau de capteurs sans fil.
Les biocapteurs sont essentiellement permanents et durent toute leur vie depuis 2005 et depuis 2005 avec Zigbee et Bluetooth.
C'est ce dont je me plaignais quand je l'ai envoyé ici, j'étais juste un enfant.
Pourquoi Zigbee, Bluetooth et ces biocapteurs ressemblent-ils exactement à cela ?
Parce que c'est comme ça que ça marche.
Les normes internationales pour l'électronique et le génie électrique utilisent un réseau étendu et 82.1 5.6 Normes électroniques pour les groupes de travail sans fil Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
Et voici les quatre cercles de leur rédaction technique décrivant ce qu'ils sont capables de faire à travers votre corps.
Et comme toujours, tu sais, nous ne devrions plus avoir de paraplégiques et tout le reste.
Ils peuvent faire bouger tes mains.
Ils surveillent la densité de vos tissus musculaires.
Ils peuvent te faire parler.
Ils le peuvent.
Et c'est ce qu'ils font en ce moment.
Ils surveillent toutes ces choses sans fil.
Comment est-ce possible Si votre corps a besoin d'un appareil portable ou utilise-t-il votre routeur, utilise-t-il votre interrupteur tel quel, utilise-t-il votre routeur ou utilise-t-il autre chose ?
Je voulais le savoir, alors je l'ai découvert.
Avec la nouvelle cybersécurité qui existe, avec le Stryker, elle doit être machine à machine, comme l'a indiqué le symposium de la DIA de.
Le problème, c'est que l'autonomie est un N9 vide attaché à votre ADN et que l'ADN génère une partie électromagnétique du corps.
Et personne n'est au courant de cela.
Ils l'appellent l'aura, ils l'appellent toutes sortes de choses.
Oh, ce sont des ovnis.
Nous ne le savons pas.
Oui, nous le savons.
Skunkworks, Raytheon.
Je viens de te montrer la photo.
Les drones peuvent travailler pendant plus de 40 ans, être payés vraiment, vraiment.
Eh bien.
Nous vous gardons dans le noir.
Cybersécurité, sécurité militaire, vous savez, sécurité nationale.
Oh, c'est UFO Skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Tout le monde le sait.
Ce sont des vendeurs.
Alors, c'est quoi tout ce truc sur les archives psychiques ?
Des scientifiques.
Ils sont inhérents aux tissus humains.
Il y avait donc un livre que je faisais lire à mes élèves lorsque j'enseignais ce sujet étant enfant.
Le voici en 1996.
Ce livre a été écrit.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la psychologie intégrale.
Et à l'intérieur, vous trouverez ce que je viens de dire à propos de la télépathie, de l'empathie, de la précognition, tout cela.
Il est attribué à certaines zones du cerveau.
Ces réseaux de capteurs sont-ils donc réduits à l'échelle nanométrique ?
Ensuite, ils l'ont installé sur un logiciel propriétaire lorsqu'ils doivent écrire pour Zigbee et Bluetooth pour ces biocapteurs permanents à vie et, vous savez, 2.1, 5.4, ils sont fixés en permanence à votre corps où.
À partir de la fréquence radio, les synchronisations.
Il y en a deux.
Ils vont extraire toute l'énergie électromagnétique, y compris la potentialisation des minéraux, de votre circulation biochimique et les transduire parce que le champ électromagnétique que vous pensiez inutile n'existait pas, et tout le monde s'est moqué de vous.
Il transpose en fait n'importe quoi par électromagnétisme.
Nous utilisons maintenant la radio synthétique.
Il s'agit d'une radio définie par logiciel.
Télépathie synthétique, juste pour agiter votre peau.
Un peu transduit électromagnétiquement à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur, en utilisant les parties de votre corps.
Alors, comment penses-tu qu'ils sont debout ?
Des données informatiques ?
De la même façon.
Les biocapteurs sont littéralement des aimants.
Ils sont fixes et ajustés en fonction de la tension.
Comment utiliser un groupe de travail sans fil ADA 2.15.5.
Et il s'agit de votre réseau local personnel.
Il s'agit également de votre réseau personnel.
Mon heure, comme vous pouvez le voir ici, le six G Maupin peut avoir ou non un réseau corporel à des fins de routage sécurisé.
Ils acheminent leurs données à travers vos tissus et je cite un échange d'informations numériques utilisant la conductivité électrique du corps humain comme réseau de données (Body Area Network).
Alors pourquoi n'avons-nous pas besoin d'une puce cérébrale ?
Parce que vous êtes sans fil depuis 6 000 ans.
La médecine chinoise, les méridiens, les chakras, ce sont les points nodaux de votre corps, la télémétrie électromagnétique.
Les biocapteurs permanents ont donc été déployés auprès de tout le monde ici en 82.1, 5.4, et ils devaient être permanents pour Zigbee et Bluetooth, et c'est ce qui les fournit.
Ensuite, le compteur de groupe de travail sans fil 2.1, 5.5 prend en charge les différents types de réseaux, puis collecte certains capteurs provenant de certains organismes uniquement, pour ouvrir le chemin le plus court, pour les premiers protocoles de routage ou pour des raisons de sécurité.
Mais lorsqu'ils les créent avec Zigbee et Bluetooth, ils doivent également sélectionner le type de tissu musculaire.
Depuis 2008, ils doivent sélectionner la chaleur pour ne pas sentir l'odeur de la mort.
Ils y ont donc travaillé jusqu'en 2011, en 2013.
Aujourd'hui, ils disposent d'environ 13 protocoles de routage différents, mais seuls trois d'entre eux sont conçus pour vous protéger des informations que vous recevez en acheminant les données dans votre corps, qui extrait les minéraux de vos globules rouges pour ce faire.
Maintenant, il ne s'agit que d'un préavis de niveau zéro très mineur, jusqu'à ce que trop d'entreprises utilisent ces statistiques mathématiquement en même temps.
Et voici à quoi cela ressemble.
Donc, dans notre petit exemple, vous pouvez également noter que ces deux sont de six, chacune a cinq nœuds qui en sortent, qu'ils ont été étiquetés ici et qu'un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq.
Donc, pour chaque petit point, vous en avez cinq de plus et ils sont tous accessibles électromagnétiquement via le cloud dans le commerce avec Zigbee et Bluetooth, ce qui, encore une fois, est en fait, vous savez, 2.1, 5.4, parce que s'ils ne l'étaient pas, ils ne pourraient pas vendre Zigbee et Bluetooth au mur.
Ils n'auraient pas pu utiliser l'Alexa de cette façon.
Tous ces éléments communiquent avec ces réseaux de capteurs, ils sont tous pilotés par des bases de données d'intelligence artificielle et ils sont tous interconnectés.
Donc, si vous êtes sans fil et que vous faites partie du même groupe de travail sans fil que votre téléphone, ce qui est en fait, vous savez, 2.1.
Ainsi, dans un vaste réseau personnel, ils acheminent leurs données par votre intermédiaire.
Depuis 2005, je peux écrire une application pour cela, puis je peux jouer avec vous comme ça parce que celles-ci sont accessibles depuis 2005.
Tu penses que les gens n'ont pas eu le temps d'acheter de la télépathie synthétique, des appareils portables ?
Tout est écrit.
Et si vous ne saviez pas en quoi il n'est pas difficile d'écrire une application et que GitHub lui donne du style avec ce que l'on appelle un langage de requête structuré, pourquoi ne pas vous adresser au backend de Microsoft, Apache et WordPress pour vous demander à tous : Bonjour, c'est l'Hadoop du style.
Donc, dans les années 90, avant que cela ne soit déployé en 2005, et par ces personnes, je veux dire l'écureuil secret de mes parents, les forces de l'ordre secrètes, tout ça pour encore une fois pour qui encore une fois, Space Force depuis 1969, renseignement électromagnétique, etc.
D'accord, ils ont donc ce qu'on appelle une interface cerveau-cerveau, une télépathie synthétique et c'est une télépathie d'égal à égal pilotée par la fréquence.
Ouais.
Et ils mettent un casque à leur bureau et ils peuvent naviguer à travers les tissus humains.
Encore une fois, ces éléments sont surveillés en temps réel.
Dites-nous si cela ne suffisait pas.
Ils vous permettent également de consulter toutes les bases de données de collection que vous voyez répertoriées ici.
Ainsi, le téléviseur, tous vos sens, le radar, le Doppler, puis les boîtes à poussière volent au-dessus de votre tête et communiquent avec le logiciel Stingray, conçu pour les différents services du shérif, en fonction du type de base de données auquel ils souhaitent s'abonner.
Donc, vous vous retrouvez avec trois corps qui marchent le long de la route.
Il y a deux corps dans une maison.
Ces corps sont maintenant utilisés par le même conducteur parce que leur corps est doté de la meilleure sécurité de la machine.
To Machine utilise uniquement ces critères et ils sont répertoriés si vous voulez lire la machine et apprendre à suivre la commande.
Et puis la clé pour séparer le nombre de fois qu'ils atteignent le nœud, le temps qu'ils attendent, soit un délai de 0,06 seconde.
Et il en va de même pour la cybersécurité pour tous.
Bonjour.
Au revoir Intermittent.
Attends, reste.
Et si vous savez quoi que ce soit sur le piratage de données à l'aide de paquets, pour de vrai, et pas seulement sur le cloud d'entreprise défini par logiciel, c'est-à-dire en utilisant principalement des logiciels, je veux dire, comme sur le plan matériel, ils séparent l'ensemble du paquet jusqu'à la couche d'adresse Mac physique de votre corps.
C'est le problème dans lequel nous nous trouvons.
C'est pourquoi nous en sommes là.
Ils sont connectés à leur moelle osseuse.
Et Cisco McCann alimente tout ce qui les entoure dans le réseau intelligent lorsque vous marchez, dansez et bougez.
Et c'est une autre partie que vous pouvez lire sur huit réseaux 2.1, 5.5 et sur les réseaux étendus 802.15.6.
Encore une fois, le problème que nous rencontrons est que lorsque vous avez trois corps qui marchent sur la route, ces deux-là émettent des tonnes de signaux vous indiquant que chaque nœud en compte cinq de plus.
Maintenant, tous ces capteurs sont en train de devenir fous.
Cette personne ici, la machine sélectionne cette personne ici, l'ADN, votre ADN, votre corps.
C'est ce qui crée le signal sécurisé que le drone utilise pour propager votre ADN.
Et c'est exactement ainsi que cela fonctionne.
Donc, pour empêcher ce drone de tirer quoi que ce soit, vous devez empêcher votre ADN de se propager.
Pourquoi feraient-ils ça ?
Donc, une dernière fois.
Si vous n'avez pas de chance et que quelqu'un est touché par une arme biologique.
Il s'agit de la transduction électrique sur le groupe de travail sans fil ouvert des réseaux étendus.
Ce en quoi tu crois n'a donc pas d'importance.
Et ça ne l'a jamais fait.
Ils ont fait tout ça ici.
Vous étiez tous les deux médiums.
Ensuite, lorsqu'ils ont transduit des humains et qu'ils font des tests réels, à savoir l'ingénierie tissulaire sans fil et le contrôle piézoélectrique total sans fil, l'atténuation neurale pour la modulation comportementale.
Nous endommageons le cerveau.
Vous voulez dire des zones nanométriques très subtiles de votre cerveau pour contrôler votre comportement.
Ensuite, nous vous envoyons voir des gens et vous disons que la thérapie cognitivo-comportementale vous aidera à programmer l'intelligence artificielle dans les besoins de Cougar.
Nous savons que si vous le répétez encore et encore, vous allez le faire.
Alors pourquoi ne répareraient-ils pas votre environnement épigénétique ?
Parce que ça ne les intéresse pas.
Ou ils en auraient parlé aux gens il y a longtemps.
Ils étudiaient le transport et ils soumettaient les gens à des tests pour évaluer leurs capacités scientifiques en bioinformatique et en génomique.
Une fois que votre corps n'a plus pu transduire ces signaux électromagnétiques, aussi anormaux, il y a trop d'énergie dans le sang, dans les os et dans le système vasculaire.
Finalement, cela affaiblit les veines, les artères, la peau, et vous avez des problèmes.
Alors tu fais semblant de te perdre dans les bois ?
Es-tu entrée dans la clandestinité ?
Je rigole.
C'est donc ce qu'ils ont fait.
Personne n'a dit la vérité.
Stingray et les forces de l'ordre ont été complètement fermées en 1972.
Le chef de police m'a donc utilisé avec mon cerveau ou, excusez-moi, mon interface machine-corps à l'époque, parce qu'ils devaient encore avoir une table d'étude contenant des nanolipides ou de l'hydrogel pour pouvoir la parcourir et la montrer sur un écran.
C'est ce que sont tous ces gardiens.
Tout le monde est donc silencieux depuis 2005 et disponible dans le commerce.
Encore une fois, la nouvelle norme en matière de cybersécurité est un réseau étendu qui peut être impliqué ou non dans un réseau personnel qui peut ou non impliquer votre iPad et tout le reste.
La cybersécurité ici, février 2022, pour l'identification numérique ouverte à six reprises le routage et les idées numériques créées à partir de votre téléphone.
C'est exact.
Fréquence et lieu de résidence de quoi ?
Votre ADN a généré une partie du corps électromagnétique accessible sans fil depuis 2005 dans le commerce.
Ils ne vous font jamais savoir que votre médecin ne l'admettra pas.
Tu vas apprendre.
Nous en parlerons.
Et si tu essaies.
Mais moque-toi de toi.
Pourquoi ?
Ne voulez-vous pas un contrôle total, des humains et les avoir sur des télécommandes pour qu'ils fassent ce que vous voulez ?
Pas de libre arbitre, pas de capacité de penser.
Je te l'ai dit.
Atténuation neuronale avec subtilité.
Quoi encore ?
Modification du comportement.
Encore une fois.
Signes vitaux, respiration.
Facile.
Appareil auditif avec moniteur de glycémie ACG.
Quelles sont les utilisations non médicales de ce que vous introduisez dans vos os ?
Parce que lorsqu'ils le font, vos globules rouges doivent fonctionner comme ils le souhaitent et ils extraient magnétiquement ces minéraux, excusez-moi, qui se trouvent sur mon épaule, directement de votre circulation sanguine.
Eh bien, données de streaming vidéo, transfert de fichiers, sports, 3D, vidéo, objets oubliés, moniteur.
Et puis, une fois de plus, vous serez autorisé à faire trois choses : les applications de divertissement, les relations publiques, les jeux et les réseaux sociaux.
Je commence à voir comment le métaverse électroceutique l'Internet des objets, l'Internet des corps, le cyberInternet des objets.
Tout est lié à l'intérieur de votre cerveau là-bas, ici.
Alors, quand j'ai essayé de dire aux gens comment je venais grâce à des projets sanguins, vous avez appris à comprendre cette partie du corps et si vous ne commencez pas à travailler avec elle, vous commencez à la découvrir.
C'est la guerre des drones.
Vous allez vous attendre, personne d'autre.
Donc, ce que vous devez faire, c'est comprendre que la seule chose que vous avez en ce moment, c'est d'abord la physiologie, c'est-à-dire admettre qu'il s'agit d'une partie du corps.
Ils l'ont fait pour un asservissement humain total et ils l'ont fait.
C'est incroyable que tout cela soit fait dans le département de police, dans les services du shérif.
Comme je l'ai dit, ils ont terminé leurs activités en 1972, ils sont capables de se parler par télépathie synthétique et avec une bande de petits enfants.
Et puis, quand nous étions adolescents, voici le reste avec le déploiement de l'interface à puce cérébrale en 2013.
Professionnellement, les gens ne le savent toujours pas.
Ils pensent toujours qu'il faut une vraie puce dans le cerveau.
Tu ne le fais pas.
Il vous suffit d'acheter une nano-antenne avec la bonne fréquence pour le réseau étendu.
C'est environ cent dollars, puis vous achetez un appareil portable de 200 dollars qui génère une télépathie synthétique qui pénètre subtilement dans vos nerfs crâniens et vous permet d'entendre tous les signaux qui vous entourent et qui sont projetés sur ces réseaux.
Ces réseaux sont connectés à tout ce qui concerne l'Internet des objets, l'Internet industriel des objets, le cybernano-Internet des corps, et moquez-vous de vos corps Internet pour eux.
Par exemple, comme si vous ne connaissiez pas les spécificités, vous devez le faire parce qu'ils ont alors dit : « Oh, mais c'est uniquement dans les hôpitaux ».
Et je réponds : « Non, non, non, non, non, non, non, non, non, non.
C'est juste stupide, je veux dire, je veux dire, c'est une conception d'ingénieur.
Pourquoi le laisserais-tu uniquement à l'hôpital ?
Je veux dire, ça ne fonctionnerait même pas de cette façon.
C'est entièrement sans fil, satellite inclus.
Donc, ce drone choisit votre ADN parce que ce MQ 9 vous a été attaché.
Souvenez-vous que je viens de le signaler et que je vais dire MQ 9.
Le 10 septembre 2020.
Intelligence artificielle Pentagon MQ Nine attachée au sol Project Maven Project Pathfinder avec détection d'objets.
C'est exact.
Dans une zone du corps cognitif, les réseaux sont de plus en plus confus parce qu'ils utilisent ce qu'on appelle un réseau antagoniste et qu'ils vous attaquent.
Parce qu'ils regardent.
Avec ces commentaires, vous pensez cognitif, car l'observation cognitive par radar vous pensez en temps réel.
Et il apparaît dans une petite tenue et ils cliquent sur un bouton.
Ils ont eu une crise cardiaque ou un accident vasculaire cérébral ou tout ce qu'ils veulent, n'importe quelle molécule, quel que soit l'état auquel nous sommes confrontés, tout cela est disponible depuis 2005.
Oh, le strict minimum.
Mes parents ont subi cette intervention, donc c'est en 1969.
Toutes les molécules de la planète, partout.
Alors, comment en sommes-nous arrivés là ?
Comment tout cela s'est-il mis en place ?
Aucune responsabilité mentale, aucun mensonge, rien.
Nous les avons simplement laissés s'en tirer comme ça d'abord.
Ils étaient subtilement électrocutés.
Beaucoup de personnes ont contracté la fibromyalgie, mais personne ne le savait.
J'ai dit, une tumeur, c'est que vous avez une tumeur, mais nous ne pouvons pas la trouver physiquement.
C'est juste que votre cerveau agit comme s'il faisait une pseudo-crise.
Donc, bon sang, nous ne savons pas pourquoi vous avez tant de crises alors.
Le lupus, la maladie de Lou Gehrig, est une maladie auto-immune.
80 % de votre système immunitaire se trouve dans cette partie invisible du corps située dans 40 à 60 % de votre système endocrinien.
C'est pourquoi toutes les hormones ne peuvent jamais être contrôlées.
Vous continuez à vous embêter avec la transduction électrique de la structure cellulaire de base de votre plus gros organe.
Allez, les gars.
Et puis ils ne le font pas.
maladies.
Oh, je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
C'est ce qu'ils font.
L'Organisation mondiale de la santé a admis que ce n'était pas à moi de raconter l'histoire du cancer, c'est pourquoi je laisse cette question ouverte.
Beaucoup de gens l'ont donc déjà découvert avec le cancer.
Ils disent : « Attends, je suis malade et maintenant tu veux que je fasse de la chimio ?
Comme quoi ?
Et oui, donc pas M.
Endo, mais maintenant nous sommes plongés dans le syndrome de mort subite de l'adulte.
Mince, nous ne savons pas pourquoi.
Et lorsqu'ils se déplacent trop et que l'oxygène est transduit dans les globules rouges, les services d'expédition d'Amazon en reçoivent trop.
Les entreprises ordinaires accordent trop d'importance à la sécurité.
Il s'agit peut-être simplement d'une entreprise ordinaire qui drague la géologie ou le sommet d'un plateau rocheux ou quoi que ce soit d'autre, le moment qu'elle extrait de votre corps pour scanner la région.
Encore une fois, il s'agit simplement d'une partie d'un groupe de travail sur les capteurs sans fil composé de l'ATO, de la 2.1, de la 5.5 et du point 4.
Mais maintenant, il utilise votre corps parce que vous êtes dans les versions 2.1, 5.6.
Et pour ce qui nous concerne, pour cela, au lieu du Stryker, c'est un satellite.
Elle a besoin de ton corps en huit ou en 2.1, 5.6.
Il s'agit de capteurs permanents à durée de vie disponibles dans le commerce depuis 2005.
Et le ministère de la Défense vous vend l'accès par le biais de la base de données en utilisant notre même recensement, le même Doppler, le chauffage et la lumière, l'endroit où vous vivez et à qui vous parlez.
C'est pourquoi je suis arrivée ici parce que je me suis rendu compte que mon comté, quel que soit le quartier dans lequel je vis, ma petite ville de 200 habitants, surveillait mon système sanguin.
C'est toujours ouvert et ça m'a fait peur.
J'ai suivi le lien et j'ai fait la lecture à l'échelle nationale et encore une fois, nous sommes en février 2022 pour le numérique.
J'ai sauté un géofencing pour attraper les gens pour qu'ils ne puissent pas quitter leur géofencing.
Mais personne ne vous a dit que vous étiez sans fil parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas vous donner la télécommande de votre propre corps ?
Alors, qu'allez-vous faire à ce sujet quand le radar vous atteindra et qu'elle sera prête à vous tuer avec son ADN ?
Parce que c'est la déclaration sur les armes autonomes létales que je n'arrêtais pas de lire dans ce manuel universitaire.
Ouais.
Donc tu ne peux pas l'entendre, n'est-ce pas ?
Votre corps ne l'entendra pas entrer, qu'il s'agisse d'un drone ou d'un transduit.
Pourtant, c'est une lumière sur ma chaîne, An Odyssey.
Il y a plein de survivants de la guerre électromagnétique, des gens comme moi sur lesquels ce matériel a été testé puis mis en œuvre à l'échelle de la gouvernance industrielle pour la Defense Intelligence Agency, le NRO ou n'importe qui d'autre.
Nous devons comprendre maintenant que vous n'avez plus de temps parce qu'ils partent en guerre.
Et ils travaillent dans ce domaine depuis 2005.
Et encore une fois, ma famille était là en 1969.
Ici, sur ma chaîne, j'enseigne la pratique du biofilm, j'enseigne l'offensive et la défense.
La défensive est excellente, car vous vous ouvrez alors à votre propre terrain et vous apprenez à écouter et à respirer réellement.
Mais la pratique offensive du biofilm a été adoptée la semaine dernière, et je vous suggère au moins de l'observer avant de l'essayer et avant de refaire quoi que ce soit qui vous est familier avec votre corps et de corriger tout ce qu'il vous a mal appris afin qu'il puisse accéder à vous à la télécommande, neutraliser votre système immunitaire, car ce qui va se passer, ce sont les charges plasmatiques.
Et si vous regardez que 2030 en parle, ces charges de plasma.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Partie électromagnétique du corps, vous allez le ressentir de toute façon.
Mais si vous avez des connaissances à l'avance, vous n'aurez pas peur et vous serez mieux préparé à observer votre environnement topologiquement et épigénétiquement et à vraiment comprendre les personnes qui sont complices de toutes ces choses vraiment diaboliques.
Ils vous diront que vos biofilms commencent réellement ou ils n'en parleront pas.
Et puis s'ils sont impliqués dans environ les deux tiers, ce sont les objectifs de ce pays qui sont concernés.
Ils feront juste semblant que cela n'a pas d'importance et que, oh, cela ne peut pas m'affecter.
Je crois que c'est le cœur de la révolution.
Ils s'en prennent à notre pays parce que nos jeunes présentent un danger biologique et ils savent à quel point il est facile d'acheter ces 400 dollars, d'être télépathiques et d'influencer les gens d'Hollywood.
Ils le font depuis longtemps.
Eh bien, maintenant ils vont encore plus loin avec les tendances de l'ingénierie tissulaire, le grossissement.
Et j'ai dit aux gens qu'ils allaient transformer le bas de votre bras en poisson.
Mais ensuite ils disent : « Oh, nous ne sommes pas ensemble ».
Et maintenant, il est là.
Il existe des médecins qui proposent de modifier l'ADN des gens et de les transformer en animaux, etc.
Oui, nous savons que c'est ce à quoi cela joue un rôle au quotidien.
OK, donc première étape, tu dois être honnête à propos de ta physiologie.
Vous avez une partie de votre corps invisible et tout le monde le sait sauf vous.
C'est un problème.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est ton corps qui est important.
Tout le corps instantanément.
Projetez maintenant ce champ.
Sports sur bateau à vapeur.
C'était complet.
Jetons un coup d'œil au biais qui ressemble en fait à de l'énergie électromagnétique, n'est-ce pas ?
Vous entendez les drones arriver.
Tu vas le sentir.
Votre corps le fait naturellement.
Algore cherche les oiseaux.
Tout ça note les lignes clés.
Les militaires les utilisent depuis longtemps.
Pourquoi ne le saviez-vous pas ?
Pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas autorisé à le savoir ?
Première étape C'est la partie de votre corps.
Deuxième étape : aller droit avec Dieu.
Prière pour les personnes qui ne font qu'un.
Jésus.
OK, eh bien, ce que tu voudras.
Physiologie.
D'abord.
C'est une partie du corps et il faut se mettre d'accord avec Dieu.
Prière pour que les gens représentent toutes les formes d'amour.
Alors pratiquez des religions, peu importe.
OK, les avis sont séparés.
Que tout ce en quoi tu crois est le devoir qui t'aime.
Savoir qu'il existe quelque chose de plus grand que vous-même.
C'est privé.
C'est personnel.
Votre âme, l'être souverain dans votre peau.
Super.
OK.
Donc, si quelqu'un avait des aimants avec réglage de tension, il les remettait aux forces de l'ordre et à la surveillance secrète, sans médecin, rien.
Depuis combien d'années ?
Puis, tout d'un coup, après que le projet ait dit : « Écoutez, je me dis : Oh mon Dieu, nous avons tellement de problèmes.
Chats, chiens et poissons rouges.
Et c'est là que j'ai vraiment eu le vent en os cette année, en avril.
Et j'ai dit : « La garce aux bulles, voici tes veines et tes artères.
Ils vont bien.
Très bien maintenant.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne font pas beaucoup d'efforts.
Mais tant d'efforts.
Ça l'est.
Observez attentivement, puis allez voir à quoi ressemble la biosphère quand elle s'y attend pleinement.
Tordu.
Condamné.
Tu n'appuies pas sur la gâchette.
Tu auras de la chance si tu peux même arriver à ma porte.
Et au fait, la précognition, encore une fois, dans le livre que je vous ai montré, les araignées mangent avec.
Alors pourquoi faites-vous toujours semblant de ne pas faire partie de leur agence de renseignement de défense ?
Des bases de données du Pentagone contenant tous vos rêves et indiquant que votre précognition est également observée parce que c'est dans vos tissus.
C'est pourquoi les araignées mangent avec.
Pareil pour Algore.
C'est tout à fait naturel et tout le monde dit toujours : « Oh, j'adore être dans la nature.
Pourquoi tous ces fils et autres choses ?
Et ils vont bientôt partir.
Et la plupart des gens ne savaient pas que nous avions tout ce plasma atomique exfoliant et tout le reste.
Nous l'avions dans les années 1800 et ils l'ont confisqué pendant 150 ans afin de vous revendre votre système immunitaire et de vous enfermer.
Maintenant qu'ils l'ont fait, nous n'avons plus votre biocarburant et la guerre électromagnétique à venir.
Tu ne survivras pas.
C'est aussi simple que cela.
Vous avez donc toutes vos chances maintenant et vous n'avez pas beaucoup de temps.
1953.
Que croyez-vous qu'ils ont maintenant ?
Vous.
Et ensuite.